لا يزال اللقاء الاخير بين وزراء الدفاع
التركيه والسوري والروسي يصنع الحدث في
الداخل السريسي ما لدى المعارضه وبينما
ابدت اغلب اصوات المعارضه السوريه رفضها
للتقارب التركيه السوريه اكتفى لائتلاف
السوري والمعارض بطلب عقد اجتماع عاجل مع
مسؤولي الحكومه التركيه ورغم رفض هذا
التقارب الا ان المعارضه السوريه لم توجه
اي انتقادات مباشره لانقره وطالبتها فقط
بتوضيحات حول هذا اللقاء
والنقطه التي استاثرت بالاهتمام الاكبر في
اعقاب هذا الاجتماع اكيد وسائل الاعلام من
تابعه للنظام السوري على موافقه تركيا
انسحاب الجيشها بالكامل من الشمال السوري
انقره لم تؤكد الخبر بشكل صريح حيث اكتفى
وزير الخارجيتها من تشاو شغله بابداء
استعداد بلاده تسليم المناطق الخاضعه
لسيطرتها للنظام حاله تحقق الاستقرار
السياسي
وفي خبر اخر في تركيا ايضا نقل مسؤول كبير
في حزب العداله والتنميه الحاكم ان الحزب
الذي يتزدعمه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان يفكر
في اجراء تغيير في موعد الانتخابات
المقرره في منتصف يونيو حزيران المقبل ورد
على سؤال بخصوص امكانيه اجراء انتخابات
مبكرا قال المتحدث باسم الحزب انه يتم بحث
عمليه تقديم موعد الانتخابات المقررات في
الثامن عشر من يونيو بسبب تزمنه مع موسم
العطله الصيفيه